edit bon soir
votre cash et de presse
m'a demandé de ne pas vous parler du
testament de johnny hallyday c'était pas
prévu rassurez vous je voulais vous
parler juste du vôtre en fait je crois
que vous avez eu la bonne idée de tout
laisser à laëtitia
et c'est quand même beaucoup plus simple
je pense faire la même chose aussi
en revanche on peut parler de celui que
vous appeliez votre frère donc vous
raconter que vous rêvez de lui en fait
je trouve ça extraordinaire et gilles
michel qui rêvent de tu peux dire l'idée
c'est à dire c'est bon ça assez altimate
d'accord ça se passe à saint tropez
johnny hallyday propose à eddy mitchell
d'aller un bal masqué avec lui un bal
costumé johnny est habillé en
mousquetaires et il prie haïti michel
gelé le temps rêve geslin que ce une
pour toi et à ce moment là le rêve var
est crypté d'or sont rentrés
puisqu'avant dit michel s'engueule avec
je ne crois pas que je m'habiller comme
ça quand même espèce de connard gp reste
le chapeau à plumes c'est
l'extraordinaire de rêver
ça arrive ce jour de ce médicament et
10,6 à vêtir en cow-boy vous auriez
accepté oui oui on a devant l'aja face à
tous les autres cas ouais il faut passer
à autre chose d'accord mais mais quand
vous rêvez de johnny hallyday est ce que
vous vous réveiller avec la gueule de
bois
non non non parce que puis lui étaient
beaucoup plus faciles à déployer que moi
donc je le coucher
je sais pas ce que vous avez vu mais
vous êtes toujours en forme nous avons
le plaisir de vous voir alors vous dites
la tournée vieilles canailles a fait du
bien à johnny je me souviens d'une
soirée formidable au restaurant à
clermont ferrand on a chanté a cappella
toutes nos mauvaises chansons on a
retrouvé un document vous chanter vos
mauvaises chansons avec lui on regarde
[Musique]
sa revue de tout mon corps
[Applaudissements]
johnny je lis et je suis mordu et vous
c'est quoi volage et volage voyage parce
que j'étais un texte extrait d'une fille
quoi volage sert l'histoire je vous la
voulez que vous un jour une fille m'a
rendu fou elle ferait donc les russes en
allant aux
ados regard
est ce que je sois règles à mon sens le
johnny chante et optic 2000 non non
alors y avait aussi des jours où avec
géniale idée vous chantiez des bonnes
chansons on regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors tu es là ce soir pour la sortie de
la même tribu volume 2 ce que je veux
dire aux gens c'est que c'est déjà
numéro un quand même hein c'est pas mal
bravo
à 71 ans le nec est numéro 1 d'une part
à des soulades ya 16 kwh à
76 non c'est extraordinaire mais pas là
[Musique]
on a quitté le coursier dans une banque
concédant une balle à 76 en numéro 9 ans
alors je vais chanter tous les titres
directement studio avec les artistes
souffrent nous alors renaud julie n'est
pas venue était fatigué d'un bep seurt
est retourné fait une tournée très lui
qui avait quand même un peu la voix dans
les talons quoi oh oui oui oui comme je
lui dis non moi je suis pas que la liste
donc je pas la voir
en tous les cas elle dit vous avez
échappé à l'album hommage ne sais rien
de pire que l'album hommage il y en a eu
plein d'albums hommage verrait refuser
vous avez dit j'avais l'impression
d'être mort le résultat était pas
satisfaisant patricia kaas reprenant le
cimetière des éléphants de façon très
masculine on sentait qu'elle ne
comprenait pas ce qu'elle chantait vous
avez viré le truc bah oui oui parce que
ça ça que les ponts quoi l'alva mais pas
sorti du tout non non non c'est mieux de
faire sa cellule parce que sinon vous
auriez génération est dit avec m pokora
vous voyez à quoi vous avez échappé aux
espagnols alors il ya aussi un autre
coffret que j'ai trouvé de formidables
s'appelle eddy mitchell acteurs en
1962 1979 l'intégrale race et tous les
studios tous les lives 23 c des
370 titres plus des raretés plus des
versions étrangères va chanter en
étranger vous veut c'est assez drôle
s'entoure en espagnol c'est pas bon
film est toujours là
ça me rassure ça moi je fume mais qu'il
a 76 ans il fume encore non mais j'ai
arrêté quatre mois un coma
ben c'est pas ça ça se passait pas si
mal que ça mais ma voix change et
j'avais une voix de flux et non
justement vous avez déclaré je me vois
pas terminée sur scène je prendrai ma
décision en fonction de ma voix il
devient de plus en plus graves le jour
où j'arrêterai de chanter je regarderai
tous les films que j'ai mis de côté il
ya de quoi faire parler du nanar ans en
se faisait pas vous arrêter au moins
je
ne peux pas arrêter vous pas un thème ou
pas restez-vous par mme nabila
c'est le côté celui d'armissan
alors notre péché de presse va demander
de vous faire une interview facile donc
on va faire l'interview facile
[Musique]
c'est très facile de dire vous préférez
la mer ou la montagne oui si
je pense à la mer voilà une bonne
réponse d'un jaoui jeudi vous avez fermé
la voiture en venant lâche pas je
convoque c'est vrai en ce sens commun on
avouera j'espère moi on n'est pas aussi
huawei
et
on a connu les gens font pas le perdre
mais maintenant ça devient n'importe
quoi alors combien de fois vous laver
les dents par jour soit 3 soit après tu
l'aimés dans le vert
mais dont mais combien en moyenne chez
les 5-6 heures très bien voilà c'est
très bien vous répondez bien fait le
ménage chez vous non non non non des
gens pour faire ça ouais c'est pas votre
femme qui fait le ménage maintenant
c'est la femme que j'ai connu c'est ce
que je dois passer dans une agence de
publicité on a appris eddy mitchell pour
une campagne pour des cigarettes
évidemment et la fille qui s'occupait du
budget vous l'avait épousée eh oui que
vous êtes toujours avec à l'ewi
j'allais faire entrer du fuel pour
l'hiver une maman je suis avec le site
cité soit 130 carrière pour avoir
l'intérieur perdent
la tête
les cheveux vous l'avez combien de fois
par semaine au moins trois fois comme
les dons par jour
qui vous fait votre banane c'est un
coiffeur
il fait des bananes elle tient qu'au
mans et du viagra bananes non
je suis content
il fait quoi pour les vacances pas grand
chose nous prouve tout ne s'est toujours
pas loin non tranquille ouais tranquille
gilles honte à toi vous pliez vos
affaires vous avez vous couchez vous
laissez tout un tas au bord du lit la
renta en tard
voilà c'est fait on a fini leur veillée
à 12h à droite de léo à gauche
à droite ou à gauche je dors je sais pas
comment dire je dors à droite sur un un
logement
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux